we don't have to look too far to find
them maybe a mirror version of our
reality is right here and here's what
would happen if we could open a portal
to a parallel
universe if this SpaceTime is flat and
stretches far beyond the limits of our
observation there is a possibility that
it holds uncountable disconnected
universes but for all we know there are
a limited number of ways the particles
in those other universes can be put
together at some point the realities
will have to start repeating
themselves that means in theory our
reality is only a small part of what's
out there and someone just like you
might be living in a parallel universe
similar to our
own and that universe may be as close as
a million trillion trillionth of a
centimeter
away